This can be determined easily.
All we need is a counter in the testing function.
I have extended the test function a bit,
such that there would be a test counter up here.
With every invocation the test counter will be increased by 1
and so that we see what's going on behind the scenes
I'm printing out the current value of test_count--
that is, the number of the test that is being executed--
and printing out the string that we're testing,
and I'm printing out its current length.
I'm also printing out the result--fail or pass.
Now let's see what we get when we're executing this.
You see this is the initial test.
This is coming from the assertion.
First test, select of foo, 20 characters long--failing.
What you can see here is that delta debugging quickly progresses
in its binary search phase from 20 to 10 to 5.
Well, 5 doesn't work so it sticks with 8.
In the 10th test already it already has determined the minimum.
However, it still tries to remove single characters in here
to make sure that the final result is really relevant.
Overall, it takes 22 tests,
but since the first test is due to the assertion,
we overall have 21.
The correct answer therefore is 21.